KYLE KEANE: All right, cool.
So projects, presentations
are going to happen.
And we're going to start
with the video games,
and then we're going to take
a cool break in the middle
to play with a collaborative
crowdsourced, cloud-based robot
that's going to try to follow
all of our collective input
in order to grab
a piece of paper
that Abhinav, the TA
for the Arduino class,
has been building
in his free time.
It's a good embarrassed face.
So that's a way to
model embarrassment.
I appreciate that because we're
all going to feel embarrassed
when we present, and that's OK.
I feel embarrassed right now
trying to get your attention
and pull you away
from your projects
because I know that that's what
you want to be doing right now.
So that's OK, we're all
going to feel embarrassed.
But we're going to share and
not in order to impress everyone
with how amazing
our project was,
but to open up a dialogue
about what we learned
and what other people
can learn from us.
So the point of coming up
and sharing your presentation
is not to get accolades
from your friends
about how amazingly
brilliant you are.
It's to share something so
that if someone's interest gets
peaked, they can go, oh cool,
how did you do that thing.
And then you have a chance to
teach them about that really
specific thing that you did.
If you were able to make a
really cute thing on the screen
move, or if you're able to make
a really cool video game work,
or if you're able to make fun
Arduino electronics projects,
this is your chance to
teach by sharing what you do
and inviting other people
to ask questions about it.
So this is not about
impressing each other.
Most of you will never--
which way are you
trying to shift me?
Oh yeah, you guys.
Most of you won't
talk after this class.
So don't worry if you do
something embarrassing,
you won't see most
of these people.
The ones that you do
exchange e-mails with them
and talk to them
after, and they're not
going to care if you do
something silly up here.
So I just want to
set the expectation
that this is not a competitive
presentation environment.
We're not getting
venture capital.
There's nothing other than
learning opportunity here.
ANDREW RINGLER: As Kyle
said, we're not competing.
Hopefully you had fun
and learned something.
Over the last two weeks,
that's the teacher's goal--
to let you have fun
and learn something.
So yeah, I think the
point of this two weeks
is to get your
feedback with Arduino,
and see what it's like to plan
a project and try to build it
and then figure out how
to do it better next time.
So that's what we do.
But that said, all your
groups did amazing.
You did so much work,
which is awesome.
And we're all excited to see
what you have to present.
Thank you.
All right.
KYLE KEANE: --there.
Is-- You're done?
ANDREW RINGLER: Yes, I'm done.
Come on in.
KYLE KEANE: All right, so
the first group to present
is going to--
I'm going to let them
come up and introduce.
So the video game
groups, when you
come up, take the microphone,
introduce your game,
demo your game--
talk about anything
that you feel inspired
to talk about if there
is a fun interesting
learning experience
or if something got you really
excited, talk about that.
Demo your game.
And then we're going to
open it up to questions.
As an audience
member, the best thing
that you can do to support
someone who's presenting
is to make occasional eye
contact and pay some attention.
And then at the end, be able to
ask a question that reflects--
I know, I'm very
explicit, but you'd
be amazed at how many
people don't make
eye contact with presenters.
And then ask
questions at the end
which reflects something
like, that looks really cool,
how did you do that.
And what you're doing is
you're setting them up
to look smart and share
something that they're
passionate about
and feel supported
and you too will have
your chance to be up here.
And I guarantee
that you will want
to have an audience
that makes eye contact
and then asks you questions
about things that were
interesting in your project.
So that you too
can feel supported
and interesting and
like people care
about what you're doing
because a lot of this class
was two weeks of
passion projects.
We don't have a lot
of structure because I
think that you're
here for two weeks
and you should opt into the
project that you want to do
and you should find people
that you want to work with.
So a lot of this
work that you've
done over the last
two weeks represents
a personal investment.
And so respect that in each
other, like everyone who's
up here presenting put a lot of
their own interest and passion
into this.
So yeah, support
support support.
All right, so first group,
are you ready to present?
All right, here you go.
[APPLAUSE]